finally tonight this week's notable
quotables many in legacy media love mass
shootings
crying white mothers our ratings gold a
gun-free zone is let's go in and let's
attack because bullets aren't coming
back at us I decided to suspend Scott
Peterson went in a dress the killer
killed the killer I don't understand why
I could still go in a store and buy a
weapon of war copycats are coming we're
gonna teach the teachers we're gonna
give them a concealed carry permit and
when they're done we don't have to
wonder what would happen if the party of
Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer won the
house in the Senate this is a blatant
power grab by Supreme Court that seems
hell-bent on drawing more Democrats et
years and tougher on Russia in the first
year that Obama wasn't eight years
combined they were doing business
overseas with a number of what we call
bad hombres Russian oligarchs this had
nothing to do with the Trump campaign I
try like hell to hide that ball spot
folks I work hard
in Jesus Christ and looking forward to
the time we're going to spend together
services
[Music]